welcome back first drafts of Prince
Harry's forthcoming Memoir reportedly
rejected by Publishers sparking concerns
he's ramped up Revelations now likely to
rock the royal family the new book is
called spare an unsubtle wine about his
life in Prince William's Shadow and it's
due out just months before King
Charles's coronation I'm sure his father
is thrilled about we're joining me now
is Vanity Fair rules to Katie Nichol and
is still in Dr Tessa Dunlop fresh from
her extraordinary performance on Good
Morning Britain today which I've
happened to catch actually you're very
fired up with old tombow I was extremely
angry on a couple of counts yes your
position is that anyone is written about
the Royals has no right to have adverse
comment about Harry uh doing his Memoir
no that's absolute twisting oh look at
what I'm about there's I've just written
a book out next week which uh I'm very
good at getting in there yeah Elizabeth
and Philip yeah and I therefore cannot
throw stones at glass houses but I do
take sincere objection to someone like
Tom Bauer since sitting there across the
table from me and having a go at Harry
and Megan raking in the money off the
back of the royal family tell me that
Tom Bauer with his ridiculous book isn't
anything okay here's what I'll say to
that a is a very good journalist and he
never gets sued and Megan is a brilliant
PR person well she might be actually I
don't mind her podcast I don't disagree
disagree that she milks that PR other
like very few people have seen but I
think on the central point he made by
way of Defense which I agree with him
about he's look in the end he's not
Prince Harry he's not given Royal titles
he's not had all the privilege and
wealth become something a royal which is
paid for by the British public it's a
completely different kettle of fish both
of you are royal authors but it's very
very different and I would say Katie
about this this book by Harry if you're
King Charles you're mourning your mother
and your father
no I'm sorry good morning I do believe
that he was sincerely missing his
parents right okay if you don't mind
I'll finish my question is mourning both
his parents he's lost in the last two
years he's taken on being king after the
longest apprenticeship in history and
obviously very protective of his wife
Camilla and the word is that Harry is
going to take down Camilla in this book
if that happens why frankly after
they've already been spray gun in the
Royals now for two years and say left
for freedom and privacy why should they
keep the titles of Duke and Duchess of
Sussex a County by the way I come from
where I have spent more time in the last
month than they've spent in their lives
I think and I've said this before I know
Tom said it as well but I said it a
while ago I had it on very good
authority from a source close to the
king that if they do trash Camilla
particularly is very very protective as
you would expect to the queen consort
and if they use this as an opportunity
to tarnish not just the reputation of
the crown but to attack Camilla that
really will I think it'll be the nail in
the company
we're talking about it they have a
popular mon Oprah right call them a
bunch of callus races are they going to
really do it all over again in a book do
you know if you don't want this book to
speak seed if it irks you that much
talking about it
it will succeed it will be a massive
number one bestseller that's not my
argument he's got to make his money back
by getting out there my point is he is
trashing the very institution yes and
the people at the head of it which have
afforded them the titles which is the
only reason anybody cares is an
extraordinary gilded cage which comes
with a dump load of privilege and lots
of problems it's a goldfish bowl from
day one princess Elizabeth grew up in
that goldfish Bowl Harry grew up in that
goldfish bowl and couldn't really find
another girl to go with him who wanted
to join him in the Goldfish Bowl which
is why Megan became his savior in many
restaurants
died one of the most beloved people in
the world indeed she did because she
never complained she never explained she
never whines she never trashed the
monarchy never trashed her family you
had her ups and downs these two in
California want their Royal cake and eat
it they want to make millions trading
off their Royal status while saying the
royal family are God awful by the way my
father's also the queen Camilla is awful
the monarchy is disgusting and they want
to make millions doing it and I believe
I believe I
they are and I believe the British
Monarchy should be broad-shouldered
enough to just let it wash over again
and that's what the queen would want I I
think I think there's there is an
inevitability that if that is what
they're setting out to do it he may not
necessarily by the way none of us have
seen these extras don't actually know
what's in them they're not paying 20
million for nothing
if that is the intention then it can be
done okay listen you're both very good
Royal authors you look very fetching in
your King's house